what kind of person makes their own scam
business and then tricks their friends
into joining how do people fall for
something that is obviously too good to
be true back in 2012 I got to find out
everything I'm about to tell you is a
hundred percent true and filled with a
bunch of bad decisions on my part so
I've changed some of the names and
specifics so here we go I'm 26 working
in New York City when I get a random
Facebook message from a guy named Daniel
I've never met him before but it shows
we went to the same high school so I
read his message hey Jeffrey I am
working with a local business team an
online distribution currently we're
growing quite a bit and we're looking
for one or two ambitious individuals
right off the bat it sounded pretty
scammy so I told them I was interested
on the phone he tells me he's looking
for a few go-getters to start a business
of their own he says it would be easy
for me I could work in my spare time at
home as often or as little as I'd like
if I was interested he wanted me to meet
with his boss I had a lot of questions
what kind of business was this exactly
um my boss can tell you more when you
speak with him and what is the name of
your company I'll explain everything
when you meet my boss I've gotten a
vague promise of money and literally no
other information so I tell him I'm in
flash forward to the day of the meeting
to prep I create a fake resume and put
it in the folder with a picture of Bill
Gates to really impress them I bought a
$20.00 oversized suit at Goodwill along
with a pair of bright yellow running
shoes I tell my real co-workers where
I'm going and that if they don't hear
from me in two hours
get worried at the hotel Daniel is
waiting for me in the lobby in a navy
blue suit completely alone let's go meet
everybody everybody who is everybody I
thought we were just meeting his boss we
get into the elevator and to my surprise
Daniel hits the down button down what on
earth could be underneath the lobby of
this hotel for the first time I start to
get a really nervous the doors open and
I am stunned we walk into a massive
ballroom with what's got to be like 200
people there is a stage with tons of
chairs and a bunch of other people
wearing the exact same navy suit is
Daniel I have no idea what's going on
Daniel tells me a presentation will be
starting shortly and takes me to the
seats where there's a bunch of other
people who look like they're in the same
situation as me I
immediately turned to the person sitting
next to me and asked do you have any
idea what is going on she says she's not
sure it's just a business opportunity do
you know the person who invited you here
not really she says the person on the
other side of me says the exact same
thing what is going on here who are
these people why did they come to this
event who in the world would come to
this with no information at all lights
dim and one of the navy suits gets on
stage and tells us we are in for a very
special treat today he introduces a man
named Joseph and all the navy suits
erupt into a huge applause cheering and
howling like this man is some kind of a
dolphin
Joseph walks up to the microphone and
proceeds to spend the next 15 minutes
telling us about what a great life he
has he's 35 years old his business is at
the diamond level he works three hours a
week and makes $150,000 a year he goes
on vacation all of the time he's got a
beautiful life he's retiring in the next
few years
and then he tells us the most important
thing of all this could be all of you he
starts pointing at people in the crowd
what would you do with an extra hundred
dollars a month what would you do with
an extra thousand dollars a month at
this point about 30 minutes have passed
and the only thing he's really talking
about is how good money is when he
finally tells us about the opportunity
you'd be starting your own business that
sells home goods and beauty products
instead of going to the store to buy
them you'd buy them from yourself hey
you got some friends who need these they
can buy them from you - why would they
support a big corporation when they can
support a friend if someone you know
joins your business you get a percentage
of whatever they make it's easy money
you don't even have to do anything for
Joseph tells us will make the diamond
level in no time
the audience is eating it up they cannot
wait to hear more this sounded like a
pyramid scheme to me the sleazeballs
at the top of the company make a ton of
money as long as a bunch of suckers keep
signing up below them these unfortunate
people will keep putting their own money
into this business losing more money
than they'll ever make by now Joseph is
wrapping up his presentation he tells us
he knows we're super excited but that we
shouldn't go telling our friends or
family about anything yet
they might have questions that we don't
know the answers to and it's better off
if we just wait he says goodbye and then
maybe seats give another excessive round
of applause everyone stands up and
Daniel makes his way back over to me so
what do you think it sounds amazing
I can see the dollar signs light up in
his eyes it takes me back to the lobby
and tells me to hang tight while he
grabs an info packet while I'm waiting
there i watch as two navy suits walk
across the entire room and stand like
two feet away from me
so what level are you at I just got the
Platinum Wow and you've only been doing
this for three months and then they
walked away they came across the entire
room and stood two feet next to me just
so I could overhear that Daniel returns
and gives me the info packet it's titled
creating choices of business of your own
and the very first page has a picture of
a sailboat on the ocean with the caption
imagine where life can take you the book
then goes on to a diagram of their
business model which is actually shaped
like a pyramid it also shows that the
only thing you need to do to start your
own business is pay $200 to get your
very own website you got to pay to play
right he puts the pressure on me to do
it right then and there but I tell him I
need a week to consider it he says okay
but he warns me not to Google anything
about the company so of course I googled
the company and immediately my browser
is filled with horror stories people
talk about losing their life savings one
lady even wrote about her brother trying
to recruit people at their father's
funeral he was a great man and these are
great products some people call it a
cult they brainwash people to convert
their entire lives to this company they
convince you it's not a scam and they
train you how to reply to anybody who
says it is they have a very special way
they want you to run your business and
it can only be learned by purchasing
their books and DVDs and paying to go to
their seminars so it's a week later and
a meeting Daniel in a cafe I get a
little nervous when he gets right down
to business when I say I don't know if
I'm gonna have enough time to do this
you could work as little or as much as
you like when I say I'm not good at
sales we have specialized training and
we can teach you how to succeed when I
say I'm not sure I want to spend $200 on
something right now
actually the startup fee is $300 wait
wait wait $300 the packet says $200 oh
yes the $200 starts up your website but
there's an extra $100 needed to get you
your first training books and videos ah
I don't think I need those oh but it's
the only way our business owners can be
successful did you buy them of course
well then can I just borrow them from
you oh I can see nobody has ever asked
him this before he gets flustered for
just a moment but then jumps right back
in no no no it's really recommended that
you buy your own why well if you
borrowed mine everyone would want to and
there wouldn't be enough to go around
I tell him I'm a really fast reader and
I even read most of the Harry Potter
books in a single weekend are any of
your training books as long as a Harry
Potter book then it wouldn't really be
difficult for me to read these quickly
right so I can just borrow yours and I
can't believe it he says I I guess I'm
using logic to get out of paying him
money I can tell that's not what he
wants he wants someone who's not gonna
ask questions I could see that for
Daniel's sake I should stop wasting his
time it's either join his team or tell
him I was messing with him so I do the
only proper thing I abruptly leave over
the next few years every now and then
I'd get little reminders of this company
I actually know someone else from high
school who joined and lost a lot of
money so after two years I decide hey
maybe I should check in with Daniel
again hey Daniel how are things at the
business did I make a mistake by not
joining you business has been cooking
like never before
well to tell you the truth I can't say
you haven't missed out but then again
sometimes the timing just isn't right
for people to be honest I was a little
bit surprised he was still with the
company but I guess that means he was
making money I guess it goes to show you
should never give up on your dream even
if your dream is scamming people
[Music]
hey guys do you know what this panic
hair chipmunk nobody you guys from
Loyola people content right here